So one of the great things about a
civilization is that
there's a whole bunch of different
people.
All the different people have different,
are curious about different things and
somehow if they all follow their own
curiosity in some way,
great stuff happens.
That's sort of what's happened so far.
I mean,
if you're in a civilization where you're
able to support people doing that,
then uh,
the civilization feels you feel happier
to be in it.
I mean,
when I read about something that,
whether it's art or biology or
sociology,
if I read about something interesting
and I realize that some humans actually
spent their whole life doing that and
it's,
and that we supported them doing it,
I f I feel like that's the,
the,
the pinnacle of civilization that's the
best.
So I think,
you know,
one of the reasons we fund these
experiments,
um,
is because we want to live in a world
where people find stuff out.
Imagine if you funded nothing in science
and you never found anything out.
How depressing would that be?
I don't know actually.
How depressing would that be that that
would be pretty depressing.
Or imagine a world in which nobody could
write books or,
yeah,
I think the reason to fund things,
and you can,
of course,
you can't argue that any stupid thing
you should fund,
but if there's a whole lot of people who
are interested in doing something and it
makes sense and they've worked on it for
years,
it's reasonable to fund it.
I think if you can,
I mean,
there's some people who believe that,
you know,
you should only fund things that make
people's lives longer,
but that seems ridiculous.
How about making people's lives better?
How about people making people happier
to be alive because they can read cool
stuff in the New York Times or whatever,
wherever in science.
So this,
so people are somehow moralistic about
the length of people's lives rather than
the quality of life or the rather than
the standard of living.
So I think by me doing particle physics,
it raises everybody's standard of
living.
That's a,
okay
boy,
maybe I shouldn't be quoted that way,
I think.
I think I do that.